yes Mark it's certainly a diplomatic
coup uh the security is interesting it
would have been pretty massive even as
we as we speak there's quite a lot of
American Air activity going on along the
Polish Ukrainian border which is what
you'd expect so well done to American
Security for creating this but there's
some diplomatic choreography going on
here because this is Biden going to
Ukraine on Monday we thought he might go
tomorrow when he's due in Poland but no
he's gone today tomorrow President Putin
gives his state of the nation address
and later in the week the Chinese go to
Moscow to Moscow and the Chinese will
launch their own peace plan for the uh
for the conflict so all three big powers
are making big statements this week but
Biden has got in first and so everybody
else will have to react to him they'll
have to bounce off what he's saying and
what he's doing rather than him react to
them so it's a diplomatic coup it's not
only a dangerous thing to do it's a
risky thing to do I think it's
diplomatically quite clever
yes it's interesting the timing what do
you make of the Chinese role in all this
now with these reports that they may be
uh considering giving Russia some sort
of Weaponry are we we're definitely
seeing aren't we a tightening of this
china-russian relationship it seems uh
well we may be yes I mean one year who
was at the he's a Chinese foreign
Ministry official he's a he's a senior
official he's not technically the
foreign minister the foreign minister is
King gang and this it's not clear quite
who is dominant in Beijing at the moment
there's a there's an interesting power
struggle I think probably going on but
one year is the man at the moment and he
was at the Munich security conference at
the weekend and he clashed with uh
blinken over attitudes towards uh the uh
the conflict and I mean Wang Yi has
hinted that the Chinese might be giving
more lethal Aid to Moscow and blinken
says we know you're planning to do it
and don't even think about it Putin of
course really needs that Chinese Aid he
needs the ammunition he needs some
missile systems the Chinese could really
help him out here on the ground in the
war but if they did that that would be a
big moment and the Americans are making
it very clear if you do that we will
notice and we will there will be
consequences we will react to that we
won't just complain about it we'll do
something
yeah and if it did happen how would that
reframe this conflict do you think well
we're guessing because in the nature of
diplomatic uh bargaining uh nobody sort
of lays out all their cards on the table
but I'm guessing that Lincoln would have
said to uh Wang Yi very clearly you know
we know this is happening don't pretend
it isn't if it does the then the the
thresholds might come down from our
point of view we might give the
ukrainians all sorts of things uh that
they would like and that we've been
holding back on and also there may be
other ways in which we might take
reaction even economic action
sanctions secondary sanctions against
Chinese firms the Chinese have been
quite worried since the beginning of
this war that a lot of their firms
dealing in Russia would be sanctioned as
secondary sanctions by the United States
and that is a credible economic threat
and I suspect that that threat may have
been made again but it's all in private
we're just speculating now
and Michael you've been following this
war for us in great detail uh over the
last few months Where Do We Stand now as
the war reaches its one year mark
well it's been through two big phases in
a way I mean the first phase was the
Russian attack and it looked at the time
they took quite quickly about 20 percent
of Ukrainian territory we thought they
would surround Kiev and maybe take care
of and we expected uh cities to fall to
the Russians the only city that they
took of any note was cursing down in the
Southwest
the ukrainians beat off the attack they
held for a while and then they began to
launch their own counter-attack so that
20 percent of of territory then as it
were stabilized as far as the ukrainians
were concerned and the ukrainians were
able to counter-attack in car give the
car give our blast and west of the
Nipper River and take Kirsten back and
so the Russians then were starting to
dig in by late September the Russians
were digging in all along the front
there and only recently have the
Russians started to try to push back and
not surprisingly the pushback has been
in the donbass so three particular
places of criminal in the north where
the Russians really have to hold that or
they lose their position in luhansk a
bakmut which is strategically not very
relevant but the Russians have pushed
and pushed and pushed and they look as
if they're trying to create a victory in
back mut uh it'd be a pyric victory if
they do but a victory by the end of the
week so they can boast about it at the
anniversary and more recently in vuladar
in the South where they've lost huge
numbers of troops uh something like 50
60 losses of volodar two completely good
units not just Wagner units good units
seem to have been completely made
inoperative in some crazy attacks down
in the South so the Russians are pushing
in three particular places I don't think
this is the beginning of the new
offensive I think this is a a
preparatory phase because they're just
throwing men at all of these areas
they're not bringing new equipment out
and they certainly not got their Air
Force involved yet I think they're
trying to pin in place Ukrainian troops
they're trying to make the ukrainians
have to stick on those areas before the
Russians launched somewhere else now we
can speculate about where that somewhere
else will be but when it happens I'm
sure it will come with a lot of air
power when we see all those bases in
Western Russia which are filled up at
the moment with Russian aircraft ready
when those aircrafts start to operate
then we'll know that the offensive has
really begun